so thank you for this interesting
introduction as a matter of fact the
level of my presentation won't be very
technical and purpose I will try to give
you two perspective one is the
expectation of big data from the
business perspective and I like to share
with you some question that i have on
some of these expectation the second
part of my talk is more on what are
their research and technological
challenges that big data is posing that
would be interesting for students for a
researcher alike but also there a couple
of questions are like to share with you
and then I will conclude with a personal
twist which is maybe looking at big data
in another angle which is typically not
really spoken in normal conferences or
another situation so the power of word
is very important because you know with
words you are raising expectation so
expectation are important so if you see
here there is a new gold or something
like that this is from the European
Commission they are strongly pushing
what they call open data so open the
data for service in the public
organization public sector but you see
the word is important because arrays
expectation so I'd like to review with
you some of these expectation from a
business perspective first and maybe
looking a little bit inside or what the
meaning of this expectation so first of
all you know what is big data which
there is around for has always been
around but now what is very interesting
is that data is not only the typical
structured data that you store in
typical relational database as we know
about it but it comes in different kind
of format or not form a little like for
example video digital pictures
intelligent sensors GPS signal and so
now all of this kind of data in volume
but especially in structure does not
really fit into a conventional database
systems you know because they are
different kind of Viennese a lot of them
so having said that
when we talk about big data typically we
need to distinguish between three
categories big data open data link it
data now in general big data if you want
to have a very rough definition is
anything that doesn't really fit into an
existing data bit because too big is too
fast or the format is too complicated
and that's actually the weather we cover
in this talk there a couple of others
aspect of data that are typically look
at especially in Europe one is called
open data that refers to a sample of
data that you want to make you freely
available for society for example for
commercial non-commercial purposes
public governments are such a case now
they have a lot of documents most of
them on paper and then they digitalize
it and then open it up is a political
act because that means you have access
to information and then you can build
you services on top of there and is it
not another way of reaching out the
citizen the third one is called linked
data is actually linked it to the
Semantic Web which basically means that
you would like to link the data together
an intelligent way in order to have a
kind of network of data interesting
thing the free communities they develop
their own tools they have their own
journal but they hardly talk to each
other interesting the vendors of big
data and unnecessary vandal open data
and linking data the scientists are
actually working kind of in parallel but
there is a kind of different angle and
to some extent is all about data but no
I will focus more on the first on big
data so that's a definition that I taken
from one of the first report that was
written by McKinsey about Big Data a
couple of years ago one of the first I
said big data in everything refers to
data sets which size is be all
the ability of typical database system
to actually capture it store and handle
it as kind of neat because in other
words data will draw and technology kind
of follow and if you start talking about
petabytes then you are on the big data
science and everything below that you
know is large amount of data but whether
it's actually fitting this definition is
now the Kami with a typical relational
database system can still handle
terabytes but when you talk about
petabytes then you are really in trouble
so the European Commission has decided
recently actually in July the digital
economy and big data is an important
topic I think he's reacting somehow to
some of the situation in the market na
issue a strategy where and it's called
the data driven economy which is
basically a document that they publish
recently in july two thousand fourteen
to promote a data driven economy in
europe that's an important statement
because then the european commission is
actually driving some other politics in
europe and europe is actually several
countries is not only one and they
realize that there is an important asset
and you need the tools you need the
skills you need the founding so as an
important priority is a statement it is
an important statement the european
commission has done quite late if you
think about it but at least you know
better later nothing so and i like to
give you an idea of some of the
expectation this is taken from the
document there's a lot of expectation no
there's an expectation that the market
will grow considerably you know much
faster than typically the law the new
job will be created and which was very
interesting the european commission is
kind of scare that we are lag behind the
united states so what they're trying to
do they try to figure it out
niche markets where they think big data
might have an imp and this niche market
are not the usual digital marketing are
not the usual fraud detection are not
the typical suspect use cases but
they're more in vertical like food
security intelligent transportation f
care energy and stuff i that i think
about it that there is a trend of
intelligence sensor like intelligent
meters coming up this is actually a
challenge for everybody so big actually
vertical markets it's going to be a new
industrial revolution well this is
actually something to be discussed i
like to share with you this light which
is taken from the pier commission just
to give you a feeling that we european
kind of feel that we're late no
especially in the development of
technology well the many reason why the
european are lagging behind first of all
there's no me innovation in or in softer
tends to happen here more than 0
sometimes in europe but in particular
when you talk about data and data is
something that is now softer it has the
meaning you know it's connected to
people for example in europe there's a
lot of rules and regulation and also
attitude towards privacy of data with
the endpoint oh i'm located in germany
and very sensitive about data ownership
and protection to an extend that each
country has his own attitude and is a
rule regulation and each of them has to
be kind of taking into account so there
is no one single Europe although data is
all over the place no and data is beyond
Europe is no its worldwide connected so
and you need the legal environment you
need to figure out different kind of
problem they're not only technical
because you know when you start basing
your decision on data then he has an
impact on society and
and there are a couple of issues that
are important and this is actually
mentioned here and of course you know
it's also a matter of investing money in
educating people building new tools and
stuff I them so what is the answer we
European community will be you'll see a
new program but the important thing is
what you want to do with the big data
it's important how people use words now
i'm taking this exactly as it's written
in this official document is an official
document they say in general analyzing
data means better results processes and
decisions now let's talk look critically
looking at this statement first you know
I'm taking the step and in pieces and
then we can start talking now in general
analyzing data means better results
processing decision it all depends on
the intention so depends on your
intention so if your intention is good
then this is going to happen if your
intention is different is not
necessarily that in general this will
lead to something better no I will talk
later for example one of the promise of
data analytics is better transparency
but better transparency is not
necessarily always something that people
want to see this is a very I'll give you
an example later on so and in the
document is written as technological
advances entire business sectors are
being reshaped by systematically
building on data analytics in a very
strong statement that I would rephrase
rather than the business with society so
are we ready to have a society being
reshaped by systematically building on
their analytics it's important to look
at issue or because these are word I
didn't write this is our official word
of the body which has the kind of
political power we like the White House
that writes the document and it has an
impact on people on research on young
people on vendo
and the thicker so I like to share with
you that sometimes the expectation have
to be really look carefully so what is
big deal is supposed to create value no
and this is the example I want to make
and this is taking from one of the first
mckinsey report you can read the list of
the supposed value one of which is
creating transparencies now let me tell
you a story I was involved I saw a
project of a large manufacturer I don't
give you the name I don't give you the
country so you have no idea is very
large he has cars and trucks all over
the world somebody marketing decided
that big day that should be really
important for the company and they
decided to start big data lab with
intention to create a better production
reducing costs and stuff like that one
of which was to reduce the cost of
maintenance or trucks the company was
selling trucks all over the world and
then we predict an elitist that they
will look around patterns they
discovered that an area in the world
with other one of these clothes as a
strange pattern they were having higher
costs now if you think about it somebody
in the company was not very pleased the
country manager of that area wasn't very
pleased because when you start digging
into the data you actually end up
discovering things that maybe people
don't want to share I'll let you just
think about it what could be the
implication so is a very political act
it's not only technology and the second
part of my talk is more about technology
but we need to be prepared to understand
that all of these nice things that are
written here sometimes means something
that goes beyond of course no segmenting
customer means you know you can probably
target a customer better and stuff like
that but other things you know you
really have to look
carefully so I think it that the real
value is combining the data together
what it means I think a ninety percent
of data is already in the hands of a
corporation and then you have maybe ten
percent of social media around and now
it's coming up this trend of the
so-called Internet of Things we're
sensor data start producing did for
example smart meters PG&E just install
it smart meters in the house I live ammo
at the moment in San Francisco it
collects data and he sends data
somewhere so this data is now there now
if you are a bank you probably know all
about your customer because you have
your database but now all of a sudden
you have other information around we've
been social media maybe some other GPS
whatever and it's important that if the
company can combine the all this
information together to express
something they might create some value
which is a challenge also technically so
I think it that's really combining data
together then when you combine the data
you have to explore the day I need to
figure it out what you're looking for
which is not obvious and once you did
some analytics or some kind of modeling
you need to be able to visualize it
otherwise nobody understand what you
have and that's the kind of search you
know let's call it based on but
sometimes people call it data search you
know combine the data data exploration
analytics visualization and here we go
then you get something that you need to
be able to understand these are some of
the typical examples of big data use
cases they're very different because you
know log analytics everybody knows
through detection is a very popular one
I'm mentioned to the last two which are
never mentioned normally that's
interesting if you look at what kinds
the report the mckinsey report as the
first two for five but the last two I
added my
so obviously data is also using polity
is also using security but people tend
not to even talk about it and talk about
the challenges of these use cases are
very different you will see that when we
talk about that the velocity of data so
when our fast you need to react data
comi you can go for merely second two
seconds so the youth kids are very
difficult digital marketing is quite
good in in seconds for detection
sometimes you have to do in milliseconds
so that's the kind of different
challenges over there the sector the
normally are look at at promising at
least from McKinsey perspective this one
here but they're more the public sector
administration as a intrinsic problem
because there is not even an incentive
for them to open up their data there's
not a business incentive for them so it
has to be a political wheel in the other
case of course you know health care is a
major issue retail everybody knows
manufacturing and all these are the
vertical that I mentioned before I
extremely promising but so one of the
consequences well this is taking again
from the European Commission first of
all the underline technical
infrastructure doesn't work very well so
you need to kind of change it that's why
is a great opportunity for researchers
and then there's a lie because all of a
sudden new challenges and new
possibility to develop different tools
different database different platform
different things and that means that you
need people with skills and typically
you need trusted environments for
example and the skill that people he
cannot have a database guy here and the
guy knows analytics here and the
business domain here because they need
to work together and my experience is
that typically when they work together
in a multi be personally team it's very
difficult even to understand the
terminology because somebody's little
best guy who knows about the core
database talking to somebody who's a
expert in analytics
they might not even understand each
other and then you need the business guy
who knows about the use case so and this
is actually important because training
of professional is very important that's
why for university also is an
opportunity but also is a challenge
because not everybody has all of these
skills and some of the tools are really
complicated so the European Commission
has come up with this kind of definition
data driven innovation DDI and I think
is interesting because they look at both
the business and the public sector
that's a very European added which i
think is good because you know there's a
business there's a public sector and I
would say the society at large I think
that's an important thing they launched
a new founding program called horizon
2020 which is basically the next
generation of founding for Applied
Research in Europe and as you can see
one of the major focuses on data so so
this is like I think you some kind of
reaction also to what is happened here
in United States and in other parts of
the world now some of the limitation
that has been mentioned when you do a
project with big data is that you really
have very few people have the skill to
run such a project so because you need
knowledge in statistic machine learning
database distributed system and somebody
will understand the use case because you
know it would be totally useless if
somebody has a great technology but then
they invent a use case which is one of
the very important facts here it also
challenge for the data scientist as a
profession now McKinsey mention some
issues that are mentioned as follow data
policy which is more on on the
technological part and I will devote the
second part of my talk and then issues
are less technologically no privacy
security intellectual property liability
access to data because you know
integrating the data
and the different in industry structure
as I mentioned the public sector is
absolutely no incentive to open the deal
in some other sector the incentives more
business oriented so just to finish this
part you know again the European
Commission as I lie to a couple of areas
of interest and I want to mention to
Internet of Things is a quite
interesting one because you know we
basically be means sensors data so
sensor that our star generating data or
the intelligent meter the smart meter is
one but you can have many more the
interesting thing is when you look at
sensor data there's a lot of noise so in
order to get the signal you need to kind
of filter all this noise and get the
value you can think the same with data
you know not only sense so the entire
you know big data is a lot of noise and
in order to extract some value you need
to filter out the signal reminds me a
lot of digital processing of signals in
fact there are some researcher you see
in San Diego they have a background in
electrical engineering and are applying
technique in digital processing for
signals to big data because some are
quite similar in some way cloud
computing is playing another role but it
requires some infrastructure and
especially he requires that the user are
willing to use it so is any technology
that's a quote I found that's
interesting I was going in in a garage
sale here in San Franciscan I found a
book a college book of media and I found
this quote as any technological social
force their reaches down to affect the
majority Society member is bound to
produce a number or controversial topics
this guy is called John bitner I'm sure
you don't know him 1977
so it was talking about TV talking about
a few other thing but if you think about
it that's the question I'm asking now
what are the true consequences of a
society being reshaped by systematically
billion data analytics that concludes my
fast overview of the business potential
now I go more into an area where is
close to my fear which is you know the
technological part and know the big data
research energies i divided in three
parts not the data part the process and
the management and I go through this the
list so if you look at the data
challenges you know you have certain
element the door comma the volume so
since you know how to deal with the size
of this big data he has to be paid
abides when you have any application
that needs paida bytes of data then you
are somehow in trouble because existing
the conventional relational database
system don't scale now the question to
ask is you know who has a need of
petabytes of data really of course
Facebook does Peter does but if you are
a bank it's unlikely that you have
petabytes of data unless the Bambi comes
to expand in the social media or unless
the car manufacturer star tracking down
all the visits of people on the website
you see is all Emma about what kind of
data you want so I think of the volume
to some extent is or even the hardest
challenge you'll see I think of the
varieties is the most important one
because handley multiplicity of types
sources and formats this is really where
the technology that we used to have for
short you know structured data everybody
knows you know I have my form I feel the
form i put into a relational database in
nice table and here we go I can query I
can up
a beautiful now let's start talking
about Road in a semi-structured and
unstructured data like logs or census
data and/or pictures and video then all
of a sudden you know it gets complicated
because the technology was not meant for
that of course you can try to stand it
but you know combining with the volume
then you start having a problem for you
have all these innovative vendors that
are in research they are trying to come
up with different kinds of technology
some example of variety so this our
example semi structure web data a be
testing session ization bought detection
path in analysis require an elitist a
scale on petabytes and graph are also an
important thing sense of data is
important i think i would like you to
pay attention to sensor data because it
will very likely become an important
factor and the issue there is separating
signal-to-noise because you don't really
need all this data think about this
mamita now you have a smarmy a lot who
as i'm smart meter at all but i go one
install now think about it where is it
going this data and for what maybe they
can tell you look you've been taking the
shower recently too often or the
temperature in your house in the last 24
hours was actually above the average or
whatever and you know and then you and
then you also receive a lot of
information you don't need because you
don't need this data every millisecond
so then you have a lots of data and it's
accumulating then a few other challenges
that are actually important data
availability is there a data available
now this seems to be like easy question
about this now because if you obey them
using data for predictive analytics and
your data is now available or is
partially available whatever you are
doing will not produce the results you
want and the dead availability might
have all kinds of limitation that are
not technical for example you can have
this
data because it's sensitive data or
because you have no ownership or because
Porkins to other reason and once you
have the data who is telling you that
this data as a good quality so determine
the quality of data sets and the
relevance to particular issue is not a
trivial case and think about a good
process will typically make that
decision if based upon that data so and
that you know this is no more database
issue this is becoming data issue you
know who is able to decide if the data
set is good for what you want to do now
if you're in health care I mean you
start worrying you know if the data sets
is not good so this is an example
mentioned there I think it's very
important but also there is a challenge
now is the interesting opportunity for
people that have something to contribute
on that part another important and often
mention challenges velocity reacting to
the flood of information in some kind of
real time now that data comes and then
you need to react of course you know not
every application has to react in the
same way you can we a batch do I store
it and they process it badge well I need
to know react on the fly but now is
different if you need to react once in
every cycle every millisecond or
whatever the velocity is the challenge
also for combustion technology and again
if you have sensor data then you can
stop them it goes the russet is an
important often not really fought
challenge because you know how can we
cope with uncertainty imposition missing
values misstatements untruth again it
goes to a data quality because at the
end if the data is not good all true
than the other problem and also now the
big challenge data discovery
out to find the data maybe the good data
is there but we're especially with web
data is quite important and at the end
of the day once you are finally able to
collect all of this data now you're not
finish you just start because need to
combine this multiple data sets from
different places in order to start doing
some kind of analytics but think about
it sometimes even know the source I
didn't even know in this particular
example of the big data lab in this car
manufacturing they were exporting data
form oracle database without even
knowing the schema and they didn't even
know what was the meaning how can you do
analytics if you don't even know the
meaning of the data so and that's some
very practical challenges as try is
needed a few solution the data
comprehensiveness we discuss it because
you know it might be the certain area
that now really cover and what are the
implication and this is a big is a big
topic because most of the time data is
linking to people and this data can
identify directly or in an indirect way
people identity now of course you could
say well it's all about attitude you
know if I live I'll cancel traces in on
the internet now I have a Facebook
account or a Google+ account and I leave
traces anyway so maybe there there's a
need of changing something but you have
to understand this is exactly the quarto
1977 very sensitive area just an example
in Europe where some our people tend to
be more sensitive somehow there is this
being a kind of legal case called the
right to be forgotten I don't know if
you heard about it but you know there
was somebody a lot of money that did
something not particularly nice and he
went on the internet all over the place
and it wasn't happy and it went up to
court and won the possibility the Google
will remove
all the links where is mentioned in
certain episode this is the right to be
forgotten Google is receiving a thousand
requests a day to remove search links
totaling under forty five thousand
requests all in Europe for something
like our minion web links the funny and
paradox thinks that this only works in
Europe which is kind of totally bizarre
because you know data is all over the
place you know you know if I'm in Asia
then I can still see it so I wanted to
say that this is really an emotional and
a very important issue that is kind of
outside our control sometimes another
important and I think an important yes
sir it could be because Google doesn't
have the day why not get it if it's a
link to the European newspaper that
actually has a story this person's
objecting to being found yes you've
broken the bond market kill you Google's
link doesn't make the data except
accessible they're not forgotten their
sure Google very much to read but yeah
we'll still has the data sure sure but
you have to also consider that the
person they have are afraid of being
visible we're not necessarily
technologies they don't want to be seen
in Google results first of course of
course is the history of the day but
these people are so afraid and they go
to court the interesting thing is now
that what has happened at Google as far
as I understand has created a kind of
internal board to this high case by case
this thousand cases which one they will
delete the links and which one will know
which doesn't seem to be actually the
solution to me because it cannot be the
company deciding which link to delete
and which are not at the same time if
you leave the decision to the outside
body then somebody's controlling the
decision so it's not an easy issue and
you'll be perfectly right is not even a
rational it should because it's like
somebody did something
is a shame of and all of a sudden that
race is all over the place now in the
first place this is a personal problem
of the guy or whatever left traces and
if you are ashamed of what you're done
that's a consequence i've been dead all
over the place if you take up a lot of
times yes they're shorter in time
whereas if you take it up google it's
still what but somebody went to core to
make sure the Guru will be then removing
the links I'm only valued the facts
which is also known as a market
opportunity for a search engine outside
of Europe maybe maybe maybe I didn't
think about it in this way but okay how
are these competitors doing currently
not selectively in Europe well I think
the the only sure didn't really wasn't
really a business issue was with a
personal issue you know that I know the
situation started with somebody was a
very high profile image and then all of
a sudden something happened and then
this was in the net and then he became
share to everybody they can simply
google the name of the guy and this guy
freaked out and since he has a lot of
money and a lot of patient he went
through all the steps and it doesn't
matter it is you can understand it has
nothing to do with logic has to do with
some kind of irrational emotional but
it's again the consequence of day it up
being chair so that's what I think is is
very much connected to what I mentioned
before I only mentioned data document is
is very important as well we should
always remember that people have a very
important role now that we think in your
prediction and aletta will be the only
way you know especially healthcare think
about you know you don't want a
completely out of my system that will
predict something for you I think the
role of domain expert will steal it has
to still be important this is the
interesting part it would be worrying if
they
f care sector only responded for flu
outbreaks when Google Flu Trends told
them no very actual now with some kind
of situation with the Ebola and stuff I
there now on the process we have a few
challenges how to capture the data not
easy so that's why there's an
opportunity once you have the data are
you align it from different sources that
means resolving conflict resolving
different semantics in order to have the
data you can transform for a suitable
form for analytics so that's the process
is no obvious especially the data is
spread around in different parts the
model how to model it and then how to
understand the output that's important
because if you down all the work and you
can't really present it and somebody can
really understand it is there now issue
visualization and sharing the results is
also an opportunity this are some of the
management challenges data privacy we
talked about the security and governance
now this is not new I mean if you think
about the even data warehouses had
already disconcert legal and ethical
concern over being exists only the
different is now that before in Denver
house you wouldn't really have the day
the data every citizen now with big data
is the much broader you reach more
people and it goes more down into
society and then people react before it
was like in Holly for technological
people bi now all of a sudden everybody
has a profile and then you start here in
the consequence is no somebody as a
profile in facebook and then the people
that are hiring somebody's are checking
their profile if you don't have profile
they think you're not so sure but if you
have something in the profile that is
not good then they think it is not good
so and these are some of the challenges
you have and also security and is an
important thing in terms of analytics
and as an interesting partnership now
the application logic should go close to
the data and not the other way around
mean normally in the in the old database
tackle database way of thinking it was
the other way around but now with this
mass of data it should be the other way
around which also poses a challenge on
the technology so until you talking
about terabytes current database system
are quite ok but when you go to
petabytes then all the classic
relational database system doesn't
really scale this is actually not
something new it was actually already
discovered by people working with
astronomy for example where yeah but
master model data and you need to put
the analogy close to the data not the
other way around you don't send the data
to the logic here is an interesting
observation so I was talking about
astronomy if you think about it you know
people that work in astronomy and there
is a guy called Alex shall I work also
with database people long time ago they
make an observation that no astronomy is
becoming a data-rich science and it was
written 2004 please notice the quote
there is everywhere never be a single
location not scalable not maintainable
is talking about astronomy data but if
you think about it not scalable to some
extent not maintainable because you know
you can't really handle it there is
everywhere interesting never be at a
single location this comes because a
evidence that universe is expanding Big
Bang and you were suspending the
interesting thing is I learn that there
is not centered so if you every any
point in the universe you will be seeing
the universe expanding but it take any
different point in the spending the same
way so there is no Center
and this is kind of somehow the same
kind of spirit that we have when the
data is overflowing us the only
difference astronomy I think it you know
for many it was not a business case now
data is becoming connected to a business
interest and then some of the experience
that the Astronomy people done our kind
of course in the format of the data is
defino but some of the challenge are the
same also an interesting quote i was
actually people that we interview a few
interesting people in the last year's
and i interviewed the city of Amazon
couple years ago and interesting quote
is especially this one that says that
when your query in the old days you know
exactly what you're craving you know
exactly what you want to ask in this new
world of analytics you kind of don't
know exactly to you exploratory so you
need all kinds of different ways of
doing analytics which is different than
the usual one in business intelligence
for example evolving over time of course
you know is pushing you know his cloud
so the second part of the quad not
constrained by resources of course
they're pushing their own cloud but the
first part of the quote is very
important because they also a positive
shift in the way analytics are done so
that's why be dead an elite is not the
same that the conventional business
intelligence that's why because you know
the way the daylight is there is
different and then you need to figure it
out without really knowing what you're
asking and figure it out what kind of
patterns you find now the interesting
thing is that if you want to analyze you
need to find the right model they might
take some time because they might not
get the right in the first place and it
should be a scale large amount of data
so that's one challenge how to do
analytics as scale and psycho how to do
in real time now in real time means
somehow you'll want to live in the batch
and then do something and give you the
result
day after you want to do it on the fly
also here real time what does it mean
you can have digital advertisement like
yahoo does a second would be fine to do
react some people in fraud detection one
avid in millisecond so that's the
difference so the requirements are
different then if you have disaster
recovery it might be really important to
be really hard real-time so we all about
the intention and the requirements but
obviously when you have real-time
analytics large amount of data with
velocity and variety that gets really
complicated and it really gets into a
situation which is different my
colleague and database decided in
October 2013 in in a kind of self
assessment report to the data big data
was an important research topic um this
the most part of the database community
I think it will be late but never less
than here we are we have five and a list
of any very important people they really
are shipping the database world and some
of the distributed system or people and
these are some of the challenges that
they found I far quite interesting that
one two three four re recovery the fifth
one is interesting because they realize
that people have a role in this process
that's important so we're not really
ready even managing diverse role of
people in this data life cycle just a
report the one can download why existing
database system are not working because
when you have a sister that was built
for structured data and with certain
kind of volume in mind and when you have
a volume that gets higher this system
nor scale no than operation like a joy
that will work by fine in
certain amount of data then when the
data gets higher in volume one scale
anymore imperil delivery system do have
a problem exactly because they were not
really meant to scale up to a certain
level so that's actually one of the
challenge that's why you have so many
vendors are coming up with new different
technology because they started to
create new kind of storage system rather
than retrofit existing technology it
scalability as we expect the data volume
we discuss it the hardware size meaning
it's your choice should I have a loss of
commodity harder for big servers but
there's a limit even to know it's called
scaling out of killing vertical
horizontal horizontal miss you have a
lot of commodity harvest and you try to
distribute your real work so the divorce
if is vertical then you have powerful
expensive machines but you reach a limit
that's the point you know you can add
big machine but then you reach limb and
concurrency because ultimately at a
certain point some of the properties
like transactional property you can't
really have it anymore and there was a
big debate and the interesting question
would you have your bank account being
handled by a no sequel database which
has no acid properties so the question
seems like you know wow everybody is
done a course in database one and then
you know that you know AC property is
very important and then you need the
clear I know strong consistency but then
if you think about it how banks work the
bank account is never perfectly
consistently updated on the spot because
it's a policy it's not about the
database is about the people is about
the internal policy so I was kind of
surprised when this discussion show that
at the end yes you can have a system has
the asset transaction properties but if
the decision to
update your bank account is taken by a
manager a day after your bank account is
not consistent is eventually consistent
of course you know people can still say
why I prefer to have a strong
consistency but these are some of the
issue when you have for example friends
in facebook and you have an eventual
consistency that means that maybe at a
certain point in time some of your
friends are not there because they're
not being updated okay so so what maybe
11 hour later you will have them so it
also depends on on the kind of a
application I think it with banking
since yesterday with money you might be
more sensitive even if eventually your
bank account will be consistent I think
an important aspect is there are so many
tools now to try to move data from all
kinds of different data size data stores
know the et al was already a difficult
task in conventional business world now
it becomes even more complicated so and
does in need of some integral tools for
integrating and moving data so here is a
debate it was actually quite well
described by my care is the database
real scientist in a keynote in 2012 and
actually say wow big deal in the Dell
buzzword early ad was peril databases
not sure enough in architecture and then
then and if you think about it for many
years there was now an open-source
parallel database and then and then in
the 90s non database people system
people people are expecting the stimulus
system revolutionize the whole thing no
then you have the Google big table the
Amazon dynamo and eventually Apache
Hadoop and all kinds of other MapReduce
and this is not a database contribution
of course there has an impact the the
database vendor the classical
re-implement
ented some relation database here are
some names you have them there so what
is the situation nowadays if you want to
analyze big data you have typically as a
sterile you are either a parallel
database or no SQL or in-memory
databases you might have a dupe
connector you still have the data
warehouses they're not going to go away
so now all of a sudden the question is
but what is the platform for big data so
you have no SQL here for example
document store key value store their
column base so as opposed to relational
your new SQL so implementational SQL for
analytics you have in memory databases
what master the data stays in memory and
of course this is due to the improvement
of the hardware before it wasn't even
thinkable you have the adop you have the
data warehouse e+ scripts or flow etl
like data transformations of also for
here is an interesting situation now if
you look at many vendors that are trying
to define an analytical big data
platform they have this kind of
variation of that question is and that's
the question for database people are we
going back to what we call in the in the
in the early days federated database
federal database and never really work
but here you have all kinds of data all
over the place but the intuition I think
is that there are so many moving parts
and if you start moving data you know
for example there in a loop and I pull
the data to do analytics and pull it
back in my work if you query but if you
start updating you start changing
something then you start a being
consistency and on top of that when you
move data from one place to another it
costs a lot of trouble so this is a the
situation that we have at the moment
which is also challenged because
so many vendors are working on solution
on that and there is not one solution to
that interesting thing you know and it's
very in research you can build your own
database Google can so they build this
spanner which is a scalable multi
version globally distributed in sinkers
replicated database interesting enough
guru replace a sharp device ql for the
adwords now this is a very crucial
business for them is a 24 by 7 business
so edwards and before they have a shot
damask you didn't scale anymore and they
create it i implemented the self another
database called f1 interesting because
google was the one they implemented the
big table so it kind of started a no SQL
movement now all of a sudden have a
database on top of spanner which is
capable at least if the claim saw and is
SQL so the question is whether SQL is
coming back I'll tell you in a minute if
you look at our dope which is the other
component which is many more component
than simply adore at the end is
typically better end this work in trying
to improve it for real time I'll
analytic but still you know when you
have a dope you don't really do
real-time analytics so that's why you
need these other tools without doing
real time analytics a couple of
interesting projects or the somebody
they are trying to go beyond the loop
and I mention here a couple of
interesting project one is in Berkeley
the mplab the probably familiar we spark
and and they spin off a company called
data bricks then in UC Irvine does the
project call Asterix DB my carry which
is trying to come up with a different
architecture and there's another project
called stratosphere in Europe where they
are trying to develop different system
than the weather this is significant
industrial is another story but this is
no research an interesting question that
I want to share with you is there is a
trend in indore civilization research in
using SQL also for analytics and
integration data stores for example SQL
H is a terabit or query grid and then
doesn't matter you know you have SQL and
then you start using SQL also for
accessing kind of a dupe or analytics is
this good now if you think about the SQL
wasn't really meant to be a language for
analytics but there's a lot of people
they know SQL out there so the problem
is a 1n you don't want to scare the
people so if you know SQL you can gently
say I give you an extension to SQL you
can then access analytics at the same
time if you are familiar with SQL and
you know about nested query some of
these nested query you can even read
after a wine because very complicated so
that's actually an interesting situation
there sometimes something that was meant
to be using one-way end up being using
another way for reason they're not
necessarily technologically based and I
think it is a trend also in research in
using SQL for large volume of data and
analytics and then those are catching on
that I think it is an interesting
question I can answer well this is a
good idea but is happening so some
people use our for example in in
statistics so that node is an
integration alar another area that I
think it requires attention is graph are
planar all in big data
about Facebook and stuff like that but
maybe some something that you don't know
it's not that familiar even Intel is
working on graph not one think we'll
Intel laughs why do they need to create
an open source ETA framework a scalable
graph that's what they do well that's
what happened the Intel lab and just
open source a scalable graph etl
framework interesting because at the end
of the day you know when you need to
analyze graph you need a lot of
computing power that's why Intel is all
the interesting graph are very important
data structure so benchmarking is
another interesting area if you look at
most of the vendors they want to
understand or faster this system but if
you have a system that is not a
classical relation database how can you
do a benchmark because our most of the
system are now no they don't qualify for
the classical TPC see benchmark since
they don't have the extra property so
you compare all these systems there's
been some early work in yahoo with the
first-ever benchmark they come that they
did it now it's not really much user
it's used but not in the in in a way
that you think is very successful but
the lesson learn is that everything is
very different and compare different
systems very difficult that's the lesson
learn so there is a research stream for
example in doing benchmark how do
benchmarking for example this is one
just to give an idea intel s come up
with the match Michael high bench what
is interesting that you don't have
anymore one workload you have several
workloads for the application you're
looking at you have a machine learning
workload analytical queries web search
micro benchmark and you try to measure
various implementation of a group
Berkeley has their own benchmark a the
TPC which is the cost
underbody launched recently in orders
this year a new benchmark Realty pc h HS
supposed to be the reply of TPC to the
factor now database on all only
relational so you need different kinds
of benchmarking I didn't really
carefully look at that but that's an
interesting reaction to the fact that
the industry is change now another
factor that is connected to analytics is
the cloud so the question is traditional
enterprise do they use the cloud and it
seems that we are in a very early
adoption for analytics or the clown and
in general people in depends and we are
back again to expectation a very
concerned about protection and securely
data although for example amazon is
doing quite good business with them so
the cloud will eventually play a role
and certain vendors are heavily involved
with that but he need to be concerned
about the expectation people here is an
interesting report by an analyst done in
2012 a gentleman was former analyst at
deutsche bank later you join ASAP but
before joining the ASAP he wrote this
statement i think they're quite
interesting is okay not sure where
everybody has a high volume of data and
there is right by this probably missing
an important point is not really the
high volume which counts is a variety so
yes i'm a bank am i know i have
petabytes of data man i'm i have all
kinds of other data that i want to
associate and he was looking at a memory
databases with great interest i think it
is an interesting technology and
especially the difficult to define
skillful people well this is actually
the correct statement will need to
double check in a few years
and I like to conclude my talk with
that's the end of this said the
technological overview as I promised I
was not very technical but it gives you
kind of a spectrum and I like to let's
say conclude in the last five minutes
with a personal touch so and I call it
big data for the common good and before
coming to this point I asked myself and
I want to share with you the following
question why in all my career's I never
been asked what I'm doing what is the
implication so I you know in our system
for example research by even a research
in industry we're not really asked if
what we do as a social implication
normally we go to conferences we publish
we write draw knows or we write softer
that is being then turning to products
and the question is I never receive a
question like hey but what are you doing
what is the implication of what you do
in terms of society and ask myself why
and I only came up with two reasons one
is the lack of up is economic and
personal incentive I don't get more
money I'm gonna get promoted and no even
come and say you're a great guy so what
should i do it it's not in the system so
and so I which kind of a a point and I
said why this is happening you know why
isn't it possible to involve all this
talent in the industry in research in
top university this one here and make an
impact you know we're doing technology
how can we just try to in your help and
I stumbled into this quote I finally
realize no big data for the common good
this is also challenge is another kind
of channel is now the challenge of the
1i i list you the business challenge the
technology challenged but maybe we could
call it the common
good challenge for big data I finally
interesting data kind is an organization
and I did a little research and yeah
there are some initiatives some from a
UN the free listing on top recently the
Eric and wendy schmidt foundation study
something called data sign for social
good fellowship which is a program at
the university of chicago where they
train data scientists for something good
badan and then there's not much more and
yeah I then I was Korean two years ago I
asked a few colleagues in different
places you know Google research IBM
research consultants and body Microsoft
why what that is not happening and none
of the reply that we see we are so
convinced that you will say we shouldn't
be done as an interesting corbett of
palmilla with the consultants that where
maybe it's just a matter of priority and
again it goes back to the incentive so
and i publish a kind of report where
there is some kind of a you know
suggestion how to make the data working
for some societal benefit and there is a
report that if you interest you can
download but i think that the true
matter and i'm concluding with this
quote is really our priority so we could
decide that our system does not have it
so I don't have any incentive I don't do
it so either we change the system but
you know the single individual cannot
really change the system or we can share
I want to share with you exactly here
then maybe we could look at this as
another challenge of big deal I'm only
taking big data because that's what I'm
doing but I think you can use it in all
kinds of other aspect of life and maybe
that would be interesting to more big
data challenges that are also as a side
product
helping in a different way not for
everybody I do not expect that this is a
topic for everybody is not a mask and I
can only share I think this is like when
there is more contribution to the
discussion at the moment and with this
I'm actually finished thank you very
much I think we're early in in the
process and so today we are using it for
economic benefit but just yesterday on
NPR I've heard about this American
trying to look at twitter social agency
you know to detect people when they're
in trouble when it was so suicidal me to
alert people so I think it's just a
matter of time before you know the
people who are familiar with the
technologies start looking at different
applications I think part of the problem
is that the people who maybe are
thinking about these issues are not the
technologists me and the technologists
against it's a little early in the
process for them to be studying to look
at a big picture but if I can make a
copperhead is a great point but what I
want to make a comedy what puzzles me is
that this tool exactly the one
developing great ideas and technology
and the one that are having a use case
or insertion they normally don't even
connect there is nothing in the cyst
that put them you know and i think i
have a feeling that one person huddle 20
might be interested only that he doesn't
know and accept i think it does in need
of maybe connecting the tools yes it's
also challenging because you go outside
your comfort zone right and who wants to
go outside your comfort zone difficult
thank you for the question for the
comment that was good yes agree with a
common good you think that implies whoop
stored data privacy or get a
transparency i think it what I meant is
neither the tool no these are issues
okay and every let's say new
technological innovation
pose a question like you know leaving
when they unload the car was invented
then behavior change so in good on that
you can decide what I meant is actually
I don't think it did the privacy is what
i meant here i think it what I meant is
is the intention how can we foster and
intention so that when you are
developing so maybe solution for big
data you have in mind certain kind of
requirements that are now obviously the
one listed from the mckinsey report
nothing wrong with the mckinsey report
don't get me wrong but it might be
interesting to connected but this is a
fake is a subject of much larger
discussion so I'm only for in the
question and of course they know data
privacy is a major major issue so
transparency so its transparency however
best phone bushes what do you think the
efforts of the United States government
did I got much bigger problems but
talent
I don't think I don't think it you know
what i think he is actually not really
this I don't think you know this is
another area which I don't want to get
into a discussion now because it's not
necessarily the common good that I think
in in terms of positive this is like a
reaction to a certain situation and then
you can start getting too much larger
discussion or there are not the data no
because you know this this discussion
has to do with another dimension as very
little to do with it has to do with what
you do when something bad happens and
how you handle that I just give an
example I visit the Alcatraz there's a
beautiful exhibition in alcatraz by a
Chinese artist and you go talk to us
then you see a place in this place of
the history and then you can jump on
yourself whether you like it or not but
there's a history there and then the
artists that put some kind of
interesting thing that's another
discussion which I think it you know is
much bigger but it's not necessarily the
the big data for the common good
alignment I don't know if I was able to
explain you on that point yes yeah yes
ultimately what is going to be the
relationship between commercial
surveillance and government surveillance
the commercial surveillance is for
commercial property their federal things
like advertising for me the more they
know the better they can target and the
government for say surveillance is the
more they know the better thing in
targeted by the interesting thing you
know I want to reverse a question and
said but what about the end user what
about the people in need what about the
guy who has a disease what about a guy
who has not now hot no home that's the
is in there too yeah but the only
target exceptions and pretty sure
lullabies all right right but also i
think is about a is a matter of focus
you know it's a matter of farkle so in
that respect this
for common good will be maybe to start a
challenge I'm going to actually share
here maybe write a challenge for the
best data scientist in the world and
some are here that we spend a little bit
at that time to maybe think of solution
for a problem for that target which is
not necessarily what we discussed maybe
it could be in health care it could be
it could be in an area where the food is
now there or disease are there and all
that kind of stuff but maybe at the end
of the day is not going to change much
but is also an interesting process of
self-reflection we have this universal
problem obesity it's it's a it's an
epidemic of enormous in size your
personal profits were probably the
United States it is not it is not it's a
problem keep breathing problem asia and
europe and an hour calgary adhere to the
same extent read your fat chance well I
can tell you start about it in the
Europe for years stavia was not allowed
stiga is this you know substance that
you can use instead of sugar increases
hunger but it was not allowed for many
years and it was no you know it's all
about also lobbies and control and you
get into a constant different interest
but it's all about intention that's what
I mentioned before laughter little bike
which were loud but that was best fire
was a big concern when I read this
statement of the European Commission say
no in general analyzing data would be
good it's all about the intention no and
they also depends who decide what to
analyze that's the good the good point
about side effects oh yeah I heard her
comment actually about just wanting to
keep up from my first business trips
here in 2000-2001 from your European
Commission numbers mm-hmm and the
problem is most people tend to think of
it as a binary situation but when I
clearly the european commission members
further they said no no we just you're
just wants to keep up with what's
happening between the United States and
and Asia in particular China because
there's all these kids are growing up
okay world's largest nation
and that the next great killer app could
actually be fully in mandarin and may
not have any direct influence to either
the United States or Europe but to just
totally overwhelm over on the market
what a lot of people don't understand is
that when the Japanese my honorable
ancestors were shooting the lunch of the
United States electronics industry back
in the 80s United States dragged its
feet a long time with the
high-definition television Stanford and
what most people don't realize is
Japanese attempted the route force the
solution with first HD systems by simply
quadrupling the bandwidth but the United
States drug its feet because it wanted
to go to digital HD not merely analog HD
and Japan bet billions of dollars on
fabrication lines to build analog
high-definition systems and all of those
systems all of that infrastructure went
down the tubes now that didn't wasn't
bad for everybody we had locally one
colleague who attempted to make use of
that fact and build slot machines using
those but his lunch got eaten up by a
different industry entirely but the
problem is what you guys in Europe are
hoping to do is at least just keep up
with what Asia principally China but the
other countries little too and the
United States do and you're trying to
for instance you're tryna say we have
value in role because of our contact we
have you know literature and all kinds
of other things and you know we're
sympathetic to that even if you don't
have the technology also what we do not
know that we don't have technology but I
think it there's a recognition that
there's a trend in the digital economy
you can't stop it whether you like it or
not so and then what to do with that I
think it is it's like in a stock Google
movement and then if this happening is
happening anyway and then the question
is how to handle the situation you can
watch it can be active but somehow is
happening anyway so I think they realize
that this is actually transformation
I'm big day that's just a name you know
it might be much more than that
you